.
Thank you.
It's 1101.
I will open the work session in Division 2 on House Bill 396 and recess for about 10 minutes.
Thank you.
I'll reconvene the work session on House Bill 396 and open the floor to comments.
Just in case.
In case you forget who you are.
He's here.
He's wandering the hall somewhere.
Okay.
I think what this bill basically is, is a big oops I think there was a authorization given to execute which was not authorized by this state but committed to by this a employee of the state uh to the detriment of the local district or though to which one was it uh palmer regional center technical education does anybody have any comments one way or the other Thanks, Mr.
Chair.
If I could just say that it was my general feeling after the hearing that it seemed like, you know, there was reliance whether or not it was, you know, an appropriate thing to do.
But there was reliance on what the state had told in an official capacity to the center.
And so they went ahead with an expense.
And so I think in law, when there is reliance, usually the court comes down on the side of the people who were wronged, who were harmed.
So the damages here are to the center.
And I think the only way to make this right is to make sure that it doesn't happen again in the future and to just correct, you know, to make the center whole for this mistake.
Mr.
Representative Pappapit.
I just want to echo what Representative Hacken-Phillips said, that in this case, the center seems to have made a good faith effort to obtain the approval.
There was a miscommunication for which the DOE graciously assumed the responsibility and assured us that the processes have already been changed so this wouldn't happen.
So I think that honestly the only right thing to do here is to correct that consequence that you know again mistakes that were made in good faith and I would support OTPing this.
I don't you't have a lot.
Thank you.
It's a work session.
I'm on.
That's funny.
Half of us are on.
I can share my microphone if you want, but I think Mary, he just moved OTP.
Is that correct?
Okay.
Motion made and seconded for OTP recommendation for full finance on House Call 396.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, unanimous.
Anything else?
Now what do we do?
We wait for one o'clock.
Go to what?
I have to look at your game.
Oh, no, no.
That's not until we're finishing.
Thank you and you want to make any comments?
Okay, so everybody's happy.
Good, all right.
Now the joint session is at one.
I'll try to get in and out.
Thank you.